رائحه الياسمين تملا المكان هنا فاصغر هذه
القريه الصغيره في مصر تساهم في تصنيع
افخم العطور حول العالم
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من
عادات وشعوب
هنا في قريه شبرا بلوله شمال العاصمه
المصريه القاهره يزرع ويقطفوا اكثر من 50
بالمئه من ياسمين العالم الذي يستخدم في
تصنيع العطور الفخمه
عندما استورد احد كبارها بذور الياسمين من
فرنسا قبل عشرات السنوات وبدا في زراعتها
على مساحات واسعه باراد القريه ثم انشاء
اول مصنعا لصناعه العجينه التي يستخلص
منها زيت الياسمين السكان هنا يفوق عددهم
الخمسين الف سنه سماء ويعملوا معظمهم في
زراعه وجمع الياسمين واستخلاص الزيوته
بيبدا يتعلم ولا لازم ديت المهنه دي بتكون
عايزه ايه انتباه وعايزه كمان يد سريعه
لان هي ما فيش اللي بتتاخذ اللي هي منوره
هنا في ارض الياسمين يبدا موسم الحصاد في
شهر يونيو وحتى نوفمبر من كل عام عند
منتصف الليل يتواجد الالاف من جامع الزهور
الى الاراضي الزراعيه لقطف الياسمين حتى
ساعات الصباح الاولى فهذه الزهره العطره
شديده الحساسيه بنسبه للضوء وبعد انتهاء
الحصاد اليومي ترسل الزهور الى منطقه
التجميع لغسلها ثم تدخل المصنع لتحويلها
الى عجينه تصدر الى فرنسا وغيرها من الدول
الاوروبيه الاستخلاص الزيت منها وصناعه
العطور والادويه الطبيه ايضا
تحديد القريه يوميا ما يصل الى 10 اطنان
من الزهور ومع كل طن يستخلص نحو ثلاثه
كيلوجرامات من عجينه الياسمين ثم يتم
تصديره بنحو 15 الف دولار للكيلو الواحد
من شهر سته ينتهي في شهر 11 حوالي
مبيعات المصانع الخارج
وحسب احساس الاتحاد الدولي لتجاره الزيوت
والعطور لعام 2015
فان مصر والهند هما المنتجان الرئيسيان
لنحو 95% من عجينه الياسمين في العالم
[موسيقى]
وبقيت رائحته العاطره عالقه في اذهانكم
حتى الان
[موسيقى]